eldon ring is a game that's so big and
so complex that one might just get lost
in its world forever nah i'm just
kidding it's huge alright but i've
personally beaten the game twice already
and am working on my third playthrough
and i'm far from alone in this in fact
i'm kind of a slowpoke all of my friends
who played through the game with me
initially and most of the fan base i see
online are also done with at least one
playthrough with many people being on
there like sixth or ninth i'm not trying
to say that elden rings world is small
or anything far from it but what i am
saying is that now that everyone's done
or nearly done with the game we've
started to wonder about what's next
which is just natural all things
considered see given from software's
previous tendency to release dlc for
their other soulsborne titles as in
literally every one of them except for
demon souls and sakura it is inevitable
in my and lots of others opinions that
dlc is what's next for eldon ring or at
least it's inevitable that we would
expect dlc for such an amazing game and
technically speaking they have already
given us some mini dlc content starting
back in march patch 1.03 started off by
adding the brand new character jar baron
into the game and added new quest phases
for a lot of already existing npcs and
if new characters and content being
added after a game's release isn't the
definition of dlc i don't know what is
with that in mind i can't help but
wonder where in the wide world of the
lore filled lands between would work
best for future dlc expansions and as
someone who has delved the depths of
elden rings limitless hidden secrets and
storylines and has even read through the
entire game script multiple times here
are my top 5 picks for what would be the
coolest and most impactful and most
probable expansion areas or ideas for
elden ring and future dlc by the way
real quick before we get into it if you
like to geek out about games whether it
be their lore or what makes them so fun
and especially if this isn't the first
time you're hearing my voice i'm talking
to you then 90 out there you should
consider subscribing to the channel
you'll get notified of my new uploads
which chances are will be about games
you love and you can always unsubscribe
if you change your mind either way i
look forward to seeing you around number
one nicholas egg this is probably the
most obvious pick of the bunch and for
good reason for those who are unfamiliar
with the character of mikola he is the
twin brother of millennia and is a
demigod just like his sister and all of
his step siblings in fact he's the only
demigod in the entire game that we don't
get to kill i mean encounter and like
his sister he's a rare empyrean and has
suffered from afflictions since birth
millennia was cursed to harbor the
scarlet rot inside her body and mykola
is cursed to have the body of a child
forever this may be because their
emperians and outer gods housed their
essence in them or it might be because
they're inbred it depends on who you ask
but despite his appearance mikala was
apparently extremely intelligent
strangely very likable and was somewhat
of an inventor before all went to hell
with the shattering of the elden ring
millennia even describes him as the most
fearsome demigod of them all in regard
to his wisdom and allure prior to being
in this giant egg in moguin palace
underneath the lands between mykola was
actually located way across the land to
the far north where he was nursing his
own great tree called the halig tree
with his own blood you can actually see
the exact spot where he was previously
located which notably features his image
in the roots at the base of the halak
tree where you fight his sister
millennia he was kidnapped from his
position here by his omen laden half
brother named moog while millennia was
off fighting their other half-brother
general radon for other reasons moog
kidnapped mykola because he wanted
mikala an imperian to be the vassal for
the outer god that he was serving called
the formless mother now this is where it
gets even creepier than kidnapping your
half-brother who looks like a child moog
wanted to be the consort of his
half-brother but mikala kept refusing to
do
certain things with moog in his bed
chamber which i suppose is why moog
decided to put mikala in this egg cocoon
thing to germinate or something now
obviously there are a lot of lore
implications in pretty much everything i
just said in fact there's enough there
to make an entire other video or videos
about so i won't go into explaining all
of that right now but that is precisely
why i and many others feel like it would
be a very welcome choice should eldon
ring's dlc feature mykolo awakening from
the egg he's currently in or maybe
having the player enter the egg to be
transported to the dimension of the
formless mother or something like that
it would offer so much on the characters
of both mykola and moog and potentially
some other glimpses into other outer
gods also there's no real reason to
assume he's dead in there since moog
still declares that his mogwin dynasty
is coming to be implying the vassal
mikula isn't dead unless he is and moog
really just like sloshing around in the
blood of his dead siblings which i guess
i wouldn't put past him all things
considered next up would be the lands
outside the lands between any elder ring
player worth their salt knows that there
are multiple different worlds or lands
or areas that exist outside the lands
between that are referenced in the game
you've got the land of the reeds which
is where the race of humans
appropriately named the reeds originates
from it would be a great addition to not
only the world building of elden ring in
general but also to some specific and
very important characters such as queen
america herself who famously comes from
the land of the newman outside the lands
between she's even said to have strong
ties to the black knife assassins who
get this also hail from the land of the
newman and both parties are shrouded in
what should be illegal amounts of
mystery because let's be honest we still
don't know what the hell is going on
with them or how they're connected
exactly especially given that the
assassins killed merica's favorite son
being able to experience an alternate
campaign in one of these far away lands
or even the land where the tarnished
were banished too following their exile
from the lands between would undoubtedly
go a long way to understanding some of
the most integral pieces of eldon ring
lore or it could make things worse i
suppose that's also possible number next
speaking of other lands what about the
lands underneath compared to the
overworld of the lands between we've
only discovered a tiny amount of what
could possibly be explorable areas under
the ground i mean look at all this
unused space but not only would this
physically be a very possible addition
that i could see happening in dlc using
space that's already set in the game but
it would also once again give more
background on important lore which is
very valuable to people like me there
are so many questions that need
answering about the mimic tiers and the
backstories of what happened to the
people groups that used to live in the
eternal cities not to mention the
connections with the race of the
dragonkin which were apparently also
beings that were created to possibly
achieve immortality and of course
there's also godwin who was famously
killed on the night of the black knives
which i alluded to earlier and then all
of a sudden has appeared here underneath
the world at the roots of the great tree
as a giant clam-faced fish man some
answers would be nice and more items and
exploration deon and would most likely
do the trick number four that weird rock
in the ocean now okay this one probably
sounds kind of random and weird to some
of you but just hear me out i'm a bit of
a weird case alright i'm definitely not
ocd in real life but when it comes to
exploring games and learning the lore of
a new universe i definitely am i notice
all the little things on game maps
especially the one in eldon ring because
most of them eventually get explored
especially if something about them
sticks out like a hole in a mountain or
a body of water in the middle of land or
a castle on top of a hill this rock in
the middle of the sea sticks out to me
because the water looks like it's
receding around it and you've gotta
admit that's kinda strange and yes this
could definitely be nothing more than
just the artist behind making the map
for the game getting a little bored and
throwing some weird stuff in the ocean
for fun i mean there are ships present
in other places and it's not like
they're explorable but i can't help but
feel like somehow it looks like a breach
into under the surface of the water kind
of like how we breached the surface of
the land after defeating general radon
and i can't help but wonder about just
how cool it would be to explore a cavern
that was previously sealed under the
water in eldon ring complete with
aquatic enemies and new creative bosses
and of course new treasures with new
lore i don't think there's ever been a
level styled like this in previous
fromsoft games so it would definitely be
a win in my book before we get to the
final entry in my dlc prediction slash
wishlist here's a quick honorable
mention it would be nice to eventually
be able to explore inside of the
coliseums that are present all
throughout the game i'm not sure how
much more they would add to the game but
it was always so strange to me that they
would even be in the game if their only
purpose was to give an extremely slight
understanding to like two item
descriptions i mean seriously other than
that they're largely forgettable there's
got to be something more planned for
them there's even already some lore
associated with them apparently fighting
inside the coliseums was heralded as
some sort of holy rite of passage for
warriors to die in honorable death and
receive an urgery burial as reward for
dying honorably this practice also
apparently died out around the time that
radigan came to leadership as the second
elden lord slash queen yeah it's weird
i've already talked about it in other
videos but the point is it could
possibly enable us to not only fight
some new bosses in some really cool
circumstances but also possibly receive
some new pieces of lore regarding
everyone's favorite complicated king
figure ratigan and it could also offer
some insight into the warrior jars but
besides these things there's not much
more to be said about the coliseums
themselves so let's move on last but
most definitely not least would be the
distant past that's right you heard me
the history of the lands between listen
if they could do it for fair missoula
they could do it for sections of the
rest of the world the amount of
potential for extra backstory here is
unparalleled in fact i can't even go
over it all i probably don't even have
to allowing us to experience the story
of long ago would possibly explain more
about america or ratigan or the first
eldon lord who was apparently a dragon
before the age of the herd tree or the
great tree also before the age of the
urgery the list goes on and on and on
not to mention the possible explanation
as to what came first the elden ring or
the greater will which one was the
chicken and which one was the egg i
placed the distant pass at the end of my
list because it has the highest
potential by far for important lore
editions and it's also pretty likely
given that they would only really have
to redesign sections of the map that are
already built and build upon characters
that are already there make it happen
miyazaki but of course this is all just
my list based on what i believe is
possible mixed with what i believe would
be most enjoyable with a little bit of
geekiness dashed in there but what do
you guys think is there another area or
maybe even another character that you'd
like to see fleshed out in dlc let me
know in the comments below also thank
you so much for watching if you're still
watching please consider leaving a like
below if you enjoyed this video and
subscribe if you haven't already for
many more geeky videos to come huge
thanks as always to my banner crew of
which i have a new name to announce
please say hello to tiny elf who just
joined up you guys are all amazing and
are what keeps me going so again thank
you all so much that's about all i've
got for this one so head on over to my
socials to keep up to date besides that
i hope you all have a wonderful rest of
your day this is bandit looking forward
to seeing you next time and signing out
[Music]
you